no need to give to a single best
church's Brendan Greeley aetna is
acquiring Humana that is a 35 billion
dollar deal anthem and Cigna maybe next
what is driving this ma that is the
subject of our single best chart Tom we
are looking at growth in health care
costs so this is not premium growth is
the underlying cost and what's happening
is you're seeing a chain reaction there
has been since the past since the
Affordable Care Act passed 50 billion
dollars in mergers in a primary care
provider so hospitals and what we're
seeing right now is insurers are trying
to keep up that growth there was a brief
dip because the recession you see that
spike there in 2014 right after the the
marketplace is kicked in the long-term
trend however is going to continue to
climb people are getting older more
people are requiring insurance there's a
lot more money in that pool in its way
above inflation I mean the rehab grows
within the sector is breath yeah I
taking what does that say about the
Affordable Care Act well it seems like
there are two problems to fix in health
care one of them is making sure that
people are covered the other one is
dealing with runaway costs so we've we
are we have addressed one there is a lot
more to do to address the second which
is runaway costs there were some
experiments in the Affordable Care Act
some of them have borne fruit changing
the way people provide a coverage but
you know we really haven't addressed
this huge problem you know as I think
everybody the table knows our health
care spending per capita is beyond all
proportion of any other country spending
a slowing though spending us we quote
the growth of sunday the growth of
spending slowly as long as you see in
that chart you know long term again
people are getting older those costs are
rising and so one of the things that
will be looking for is as you know we do
not have a single-payer system but you
know as we see these consolidations how
much will justice allow these murders to
go on we have the top four now
considering deals with each other